Sudan is moving towards a Civil War as
violence rises in the capital
[Music]
two rival generals and their armies are
fighting for control in the city of
hakthun and the battle is spreading
across the country three billion dollars
in Aid is needed to help Sudan's Refugee
crisis around a million people have been
displaced after intense fighting broke
out a month ago so let me get you up to
speed on what's Happening Here and show
you how Sudan's location here near the
Suez Canal in the Horn of Africa makes
it geopolitically important which is one
reason why Faraway countries are
watching this conflict and preparing to
get involved to secure their interests
and to influence the next chapter of
this country's history policy broke out
in Sudan in mid-april we've seen it on
the streets and in the sky daring
evacuation of the American Embassy in
Sudan more than 400 people have died
close to 4 000 wounded and a watching
world is asking what's happening in
Sudan
before we dive into this story which I'm
very excited to share with you I need to
thank the sponsor of today's video which
is a service I have been using a lot
lately it is called incognate and it is
a game changer for years I have been in
a war with data Brokers data Brokers are
companies that you don't know anything
about you've never heard of but they
operate behind the scenes and they know
a lot about you and me they make a
business out of scrubbing the internet
for information about us and then they
sell that information to corporations
who then use that information to Market
to us
data Brokers are the reason that my
phone is always getting spammed data
Brokers are the reason that my email
inbox is a nightmare data Brokers are
the reason that my mailbox is full of
junk mail I feel so violated by all of
this and I want to be done with it and
that's what incognate does incognate
understands how the whole data broker
World works it's intentionally very
opaque and Cockney understands it and
it's super easy you sign up with them
you give them permission to act on your
behalf to go unsubscribe you from the
hundreds of lists that you are probably
on the lists that have your birthday and
your phone number and your preferences
no more I've been spending a lot of time
on the incogni dashboard where you can
see all of the data Brokers that you're
being unsubscribed to and cognate
deletes your personal information from
dozens of data Brokers the fact is we
all have rights to not be on these lists
but none of us know how to actually do
it because it's incredibly Complicated
by Design so I'm proud to say that since
I signed up for incognate I have been
taken off of dozens of these lists with
the yearly description you get Incognito
constantly monitor your name and your
private information on the open market
of data Brokers constantly scrubbing to
take it off whenever they see it there's
a link in my description it is
incognito.com Johnny Harris clicking
that link helps support this channel but
it also gets you a sweet discount on
incogni 60 off when you sign up using
that link with the annual plan they're
constantly monitoring to make sure that
your name doesn't make it back on these
lists I'm very happy thank you Incognito
for sponsoring today's video and for
existing I didn't know you existed until
you came to sponsor a video and I'm very
grateful you exist okay let's get back
to the video I'm excited to share with
you this story
Sudan has been in Conflict since its
founding with the first Civil War
starting a year before they gained
independence from the British yes the
country's Independence has just been
officially recognized by Britain and
Egypt the fighting has often been
between the North and the South fighting
over control over representation and
because Sudan has oil and gold these
conflicts have always attracted
Outsiders looking to support the side
that would serve their interests the
conflict today has a lot to do with the
actions of one man Omar abashir
a Sudanese army colonel who took over
the government in a bloodless coup in
the late 80s during the country's second
Civil War he quickly dissolved the
Sudanese Parliament he banned political
parties he introduced Islamic law and
became a military dictator and in order
to secure his power and fend off
opposition he assembled a group of
militias here in the west of the country
to make his own personal military force
this military force was led by a
commander nicknamed hametti so by the
early 2000s Sudan's dictator commands
two armies the Sudanese Armed Forces but
also this special unit of loyal Fighters
that he assembled from these militias he
uses this Force to Stamp Out whoever he
needs to in order to stay in power
especially over here in the Darfur
region where non-arab groups felt
neglected by the government and wanted
to break away but al-Bashir uses his
special military force to Massacre these
Rebels leading to the mass murder of
hundreds of thousands and displacing
millions of people in the process
albashir eventually rebranded his
personal Army to be called the rapid
support forces and it wasn't just an
army a trove of leaked bank and
corporate documents show that this Army
is also a lucrative business Empire that
captures gold mines runs smuggling
operations patrols the borders and
provides its Fighters for hire in
regional conflict and facilitates a
profitable gold trade with foreign
powers like Russia and the United Arab
Emirates one document details the
delivery of 30 million dollars worth of
gold bars from Sudan to Dubai from the
company owned by hemeti the leader of
this Army and this is a key part of this
story because in addition to helping
albashir the dictator stay in power the
rsf also made this warlord hemeti Super
Rich because he was able to use his tens
of thousands of soldiers to control both
the gold market and the borders of Sudan
okay so it's 2005 the conflict in Darfur
is just getting started but the Civil
War that has been raging for decades
between the North and the South comes to
an end by 2011 its result is a formal
division South Sudan finally breaks away
and becomes the world's newest country a
nation is
but with them they take 75 percent of
the oil reserves a major blow to Sudan's
economy so inflation runs wild food
prices rise and albashir doesn't have
enough money to continue his system of
bribes and tributes to political Elites
in the military the quality of life in
Sudan plummets and by 2019 they had had
enough
thank you
all over the country the people take to
the streets and protest their dictator
demanding democracy the Sudanese Army
and the rsf these two separate military
organizations both see what's coming
they team up and overthrow albashir
sending him to prison and taking over
the government it was the end of 2019
and Omar al-bashir's 30 years of
dictatorship Drew to a close and now the
Sudanese Army leader General Abdel fatah
al-burhan was in charge closely followed
by the rsf warlord billionaire hametti
they're cooperating in this transition
and they promise the protesters that
they will eventually hand the country
over to a civilian leader who will bring
in a democracy but the military leaders
keep going back on their promise they
keep ruling the country for years and
they continuously abuse and Massacre the
protesters this all comes to a head in
December 2022 when alberhan agrees to
indeed give control of the government
back to the civilians but he has one big
condition he wants the r SF to no longer
be an independent military he wants it
to be folded into the official Sudanese
Army so that he would control it not
hemeti and this is where a conflict
starts to brew hameti this warlord who
has made hundreds of millions of dollars
thanks to his command over this Army
doesn't like this idea he's not going to
let his lucrative business military
Empire get swallowed by the government
so he decides that he only has one
choice to overthrow the government and
lead the country himself
on April 15 2023 hametti sends 2 000 of
his men to alberhan's personal residence
which is a military compound it leads to
a shootout where 35 guards are killed
alberhan narrowly escapes but the
conflict spreads throughout the capital
of Khartoum and the country as a whole
these two forces that the previous
dictator used for different purposes now
fighting over who will rule the country
tanks roll through the city and Air
strikes boom in residential
neighborhoods embassies empty as foreign
countries evacuate their citizens but
for many Sudanese civilians a Quick
Escape isn't an option there are no
helicopter rescues no International
convoys coming for them so they pack up
and leave their homes fleeing the
conflict and heading to neighboring
countries Egypt Chad or South Sudan
and soon this conflict that looks like
it's just between these military
generals struggling for control is
actually turning into a war that the
rest of the world has an eye on
Sudan is a geostrategically important
country it sits astride the Nile which
is the lifeline to Egypt it's home to
these ports near the vital choke points
of our global economy the Suez Canal and
the Horn of Africa where 10 percent of
World Trade passes through including
huge amounts of oil powerful countries
around the globe are always trying to
put military bases here they want to
control bases and ports simply because
of its vital importance for global trade
Sudan is also loaded with resources gold
zinc silver chromite and iron this is
stuff that foreign countries want and
need so powerful countries are watching
this military commander Showdown and
evaluating who they should support who
will best secure their interests in the
future gunfire in Sudan's capital
Khartoum fractured Friday start the
United Arab Emirates is a huge player in
all of this they buy and refine the
majority of Sudan's gold and a lot of it
comes from hemeti and his military
business Empire the UAE has also paid
hametti to use some of his soldiers to
fight on their side in Yemen so there's
this mutually beneficial alignment and
relationship between these two but the
Sudanese Armed Forces also have fought
in Yemen in recent years and the UAE has
made deals with the military government
to secure ports and access to minerals
so the UAE is now in a situation where
they've bolstered both sides of this now
conflict and then there's Libya where
this warlord Khalifa haftar has strong
connections to hemeti hametti has also
loaned out some of his fighters to go to
Libya to fight on haftar's side so now
haftar is returning the favor supporting
his warlord Ally by sending fuel
shipments to the rsf haftar is really
important in all of this because if
other countries like the UAE do decide
to send money or weapons to hametti they
can use haftar and his Network as the
middleman in fact this is already
happening haftar is already working as a
middleman to transfer supplies and
weapons to the rsf on behalf of Russia
yeah
Russia is already here in the form of
the private military called the Wagner
group they've been in Sudan for years
supplying training for the rsf in
exchange for getting in on the lucrative
gold trade in Sudan and while Russia has
also worked with the Sudanese Army in
the past a recent CNN investigation
shows that Russia is sending significant
support for the rsf implying that
they've chosen a side in this conflict
but there doesn't seem to be any real
loyalty here Russia will likely shift to
favor any leader who will likely win in
this who will support Russian interests
and in facilitating their goal to
eventually build a naval base here in
the Red Sea and then you've got the
neighbor to the north Egypt who has to
walk a fine line in how they support
this conflict Egypt more naturally
aligns with the government and the
military of Sudan but they can't
publicly be against the rsf they can't
choose a side quite yet that's because
the Egyptian economy is in trouble their
currency has lost over half its value
and they've been asking for help from
the UAE who has sent them a hundred
billion dollars in cash and other Aid
since 2 2013 it would be unwise for
Egypt to be on the opposite side of the
UAE on this their economy depends on
them so they're maintaining a mostly
neutral stance for now Ethiopia and
Eritrea are both for now neutral though
Ethiopia has invited General Abraham to
visit in recent months and Eritrea
invited his enemy hametti for a visit as
well signaling that they may land on
opposite sides in the future of this
conflict meanwhile Saudi Arabia and the
United States are offering to act as
mediators hoping for a peaceful
resolution and some are looking to China
who recently negotiated a deal with
Saudi Arabia and Iran China might use
this as another moment to flex its new
diplomatic muscles and broker a piece in
Sudan this conflict between two generals
is more than it appears it has the
potential to spiral into a full-on proxy
war both by Regional Partners who bear
the brunt of this conflict but also
foreign powers who care much more about
securing their own interests than the
devastating human effects of the
conflict they are fueling and worse in
Sudan we see a conflict where the main
players these two generals are both
incentivized to keep playing the same
game that the once dictator Omar
al-Bashir designed where a broken system
delivers power and riches to a few at
the top incentivizing them to keep this
system divided and broken just as
albashir designed it
[Music]
and in the process killing the momentum
of the budding democracy movement in
Sudan this protest movement that
successfully took out the dictator and
this movement that was good for the
people has once again been snatched away
by a greedy few and there seems to be no
end in sight
foreign
[Music]